thank you to Rocket money for sponsoring
this video more on them after the
reaction well how's it going there
citizens of the reject Nation we are
here and it is time for another solo
Motion Picture reaction I I don't know
what this this thing is right here I was
trying to do a gym carry impression but
you know it's been a minute since I've
watched some Peak JY and that's what
we're here to rectify today we're
watching The Mask my friends and I know
what you're thinking John how have you
not seen the mask great question I
remember kids loving this movie growing
up it's been built up very much over
time we weren't a Jim Carrey house
Growing Up So suffice it to say I got
some gaps to fill in and you guys are
here to help me out with that leave a
like for going back in time for
Nostalgia for big faces and uh also
don't forget to subscribe hit that
notification Bell thank thank you very
much to prepper for helping to edit down
these highlights it is a tough task and
we appreciate them for it also if you
want to get the full mask experience
alongside me come on over to patreon.com
theal rejects where you can sync up with
your own copy put it in the DVD or the
Blu-ray and watch along with me we also
got a whole bunch of other stuff over
there with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included it's a blast my friends
and hey with without further Ado let's
un mask this uh the the movie roll roll
the bumper we're
done this a Dark Horse comic I knew this
was like a yeah like a based on a comic
book but I didn't realize it would be
dark
horse so they also do spawn who does
spawn speaking of what's the best
Darkhorse comic leave one of your
favorites in the comments maybe I'll
check one out hang on a
sec
oh it's been buried in the deepest
darkest depths to protect all of man
from its treacherous magic or whatever
Treasures lie
[Music]
within I love they're just opening it
right
here
oh
what a happen
dance it's also it's nice it looks like
one of those little treasure chests you
get for like a fish
tank
hey title cards too man back in the day
I feel like title cards had a certain
like tangibility it's different
now oh Luna Tunes I got those concert
tickets you wanted you're kidding for
Friday night Stanley this is great
Stanley Stanley so what time should I
pick you up my very best girlfriend just
came into town and I know she would die
to go to this could we maybe get an
extra ticket for her uhoh they're sold
out that means there's no more StubHub
man get that markup well I just can't
let her sit home all alone why don't you
just go with your friend a Stanley you
are the nicest guy really you are yeah
yeah I might have done that tonight I'm
going to take you on a Love Safari what
deep into the darkest heart of the urban
jungle does that mean oh no coco bungo
Club hottest new joint in town Coco
bungo Club only the creme de La Creme
need apply this is going to be the
perfect night on the town yes my man's
got the
cream thunder clap
excellent this already feel feels like a
like a comic book like a Kookie comic
book Selena
Kyle with the stretch Zoom
nice yep oh what this camera
Diaz say then crushing right back in
stand back and observe damn where was
this in her R wow nice smokey eye dude
uh where was this in her rise to stardom
you know you're lucky you caught me I
was just on my way out to a very you
hold this for me please I will hold
anything you want is this a fantasy can
you help
me
[Music]
what okay I guess this is
real the drawer is a metaphor what kind
of account do you have in mind I'm not
sure exactly you see I'm just terrible
with things like that this is me at the
bank that's an interesting time Mr IUS
Stanley ipus iiss kind of reminds me of
one of those what do you call it ink
blot tests War Shack test right may I
may what such a mess oh my oh of
course that's what they're there
for yep just
that you know it sort of looks like um
yes bear your psychology a young woman
riding bear back sort of a lady a diver
or
something what do you see
Mr this is a
fantasy just just a tip
there it's a power to It's supposed to
make you feel powerful oh does it work
Mr Gray will see you ow that was a
little bit of uh what's that movie where
Sharon Stone crosses her legs that one
it's the only thing I know about that
different
[Music]
plans just get your bingo card out for
for phallic and otherwise Randy metaphor
in
uendi yes okay I was like there's no way
that this is just
genuine she's really good at that though
like I can see why people fell in love
with camera Diaz immediately what do you
think it's not bad them uh motion
detectors are a pain in the yes sure oh
my God it's it's um what's his name you
talking to the doctor I do have one
question you're the doctor tyy wiy what
does nioep say about all this nothing
seen his gri man get real man everything
is his grift he owns you he owns this
club he owns this old stinking Town yeah
get real you mess with Nico you end up
taking a dirt nap hey sleeping with the
fishes he's the only one who's napping
oh
that's that's good and I'm about to give
him a serious wake up call and I'm going
to wear this around town so first we
take the bank then we take n and then my
friend school is
out
fascinating I would love if that scene
just went on for another minute while
they both just laugh back and forth at
each other I'm here for the Civic breaks
are shot and you need a new transmission
is your name Ernie hey B all I wanted
was an oil chain change oh well you
lucky You' CAU these problems now before
they cause you some serious trouble in
like 15 years I have to have a car
tonight bring around The Loner oh my
God hey you clay bar that put some fresh
paint on it that's a cool ass ride all
right and fix all the guts you get what
I mean gals want you meet my buddy
Stanley IUS humongo in the banking
business
oh he's just there he's not the door
man yo Bobby how you doing buddy ug
Charlie how you how are you how you
doing how's it going see you okay then
whoa damn dog see on the inside Charlie
got the hook up a Bobby uh Charlie
Charlie wow Charlie is a terrible sidick
that's what you call wingman in a comic
book never cross the Rope no but my
friends are on the inside hey come on
lose them ouchies you put me down right
to help I am never coming back
here
ow oh
jeez yeah man your whole drip is
[Applause]
dripping damn dude you're going to have
to jump that guy now oh oh oh oh no are
you okay I'm great really good I
just your car sir
not my car oh boy the ticket
it you are Employee of the Month there
sir but I am very
angry Jim Carrey is really good at doing
you know like you driving in a
Porche he's good at doing obviously the
the broad slapstick but still you know
tempering it with discernable
emotionality like like when he's sad or
hurt it it still comes through I'm
beginning with these viewings to
basically appreciate the dimensionality
of him as a performer Beyond just the
obvious thing's about to fall
apart
woo I felt
that
[Laughter]
yeah oh my god oh how many takes was
that that was beautiful oh my God they
must have been timing and pulling all
the pieces like
specifically
oh the world's better off with you
George Bailey don't
jump whoa oh the diver hey
Clarence and he works the savings and
loow is this going to be a secret It's a
Wonderful Life
H trash man it's swap
thing
oh oh it's got like a mask of its
[Music]
own
ah that makes more sense I was like is
he just going to put it on but it has an
Allure you have any idea what time it is
actually no
OU my new
carpet well this is coming right out of
your security deposit ipus yep my rent
hard did you do back at the laboratory
to get your bullets tightened
o I should have said that it's okay it's
all
right was that a Frankenstein joke or a
Franken hooker
joke hey the wolf the cartoon wolf I
like how many like you know Looney tuny
kind of things they're peppering in here
too just is you know
iconography
a I'll throw it one time I going to
throw it with you attached to it whoa oh
that that's going to happen
later all right Mrs
peenman Mrs peenman oh that's a
character name for you so Dr Newman
you're saying that everybody wears a
mask that's correct he V Stein we
suppress the ID our darkest desires and
adopt a more socially acceptable image
that's you man is of course the masks we
wear by the dog does trust thank you so
much for being with us today some good
cover art what are you looking for huh
yeah the dog knows you like it don't
throw it to him that's correct Wendy we
all wear masks metaphorically
speaking oh Mirror Mirror on the
wall yeah right yeah right interesting
line response to that
oh don't fall prey to its
[Music]
glamour whoa yep it's fun how much
they've teased this
oh oh
my
w shees says Taz with the Taz pillow is
there this much Ludy Tunes in the comic
oh smoken
smoken it's party time p a r t why
because I gotta yes yes yes yes you do
oh my God that suit the suspenders the
[Music]
tie oh she just wanted quiet
before I thought she was just policing
what he watches not that it's
loud oh you're like Roger Rabbit
Man okay so
like
oh
excellent
W
damn this
is
[Music]
fascinating this is a fascinating blend
of
things
oh hey get in the back he wants to
communicate this guy's breaking the
[Music]
fourth this is so
wild it's like Deadpool before Deadpool
or or maybe not but I you know depending
on the where's Coy when did they start
writing Deadpool comics 1991 February
1991 was the issue but the book was
actually released December 11th 1990 cuz
technically Comics come out earlier than
the publication date 1991 is the
Jeopardy answer 1990 if you lived it got
the time as a matter of fact I do Cubby
Cubby it's exactly 2 seconds before I
honk your nose and pull your underwear
over your head oh
[Music]
no oh from the front ah I mean it's
terrible either way but hey little anal
dwelling butt
monkey
damn nobody likes a
bhead go with the Mo having a great time
I'd like to do something for you
son we have a giraffe yes we do there
you go son get out of here you bother me
you bother me last but not least my
favorite do that magic trick where you
eat
it
hey
W tummy
[Music]
gun
is he actually shooting him or trying
to what are the physics what are the
rules with these Powers I could be oh oh
oh a super hero I could fight crime
protect the innocent Qui for World
Peace but
first truth justice in the American
way who oh first hold on to
your great great use of
props that is very
cartoon did a dream yes yes of course so
I'm protect the innocent fight crime and
all that stuff but first i'm going be
the [__] out of these guys who are
scamming me on my auto repair
ipus Stanley ipus wait a minute that's
Lieutenant kellway City Precinct you
know anything about the disturbance last
night what's that guy's name some kind
of Prowler broke in and attacked Mrs
peenman oh no you didn't hear anything
oh it wasn't a dream a 20 or buck shot 5
ft from your door at the FL see that he
put that right in my floor then he
jumped out the window this is impossible
those pajamas are impossible hey hey the
tie is impossible all right if you
remember anything unusual about last
night call me thank you and uh good luck
crack in the case
yep oh my God I'm late oh it's
7:43 keys keys where's the keys oh this
is me leaving for every shoot mil get
the keys get him find him you got this
Milo we believe in you get the
keys so he's like like a Looney Tunes
superhero essentially is that like
that's cool I always I always knew this
would be like a wacky movie you know
like a comedy obviously Jim Carry but
yeah like the idea that it's an actual
like slapstick cartoon version of the
superhero and great color contrast with
the pillow there yep complimentary
[Music]
colors
whoa careful careful Milo doesn't run
after that and jump out the window
[Music]
jeez what is it like drawn to him did it
like choose him cuz it knows he loves
Looney Proctologist standing by who you
heard me best one you can find oh my God
sorry the Proctologist line took me a
second there it is boys she broke the
case come on get out of here up Paul
Riser is it no he's got a slightly
different face where were you last night
the girls and I were looking all over
for you did you happen to look outside
in the gutter yeah this is all your
fault dude you're a horrible
wingman 40 minutes late now that's the
same as
stealing ner a more American word hath
been spoken oogling girly pictures you
might actually get some work done around
here she's a prospective client of
Stanley's oh really American sentiment I
should say the next time she comes in
you be sure to send her to my office of
course you bet
you so she's a singer performer and
she's on a crew for a Griff crime Heist
Stanley listen to me a girl like that is
always looking for the BBD a better
deal feeling the blank she's sensitive
Stanley forget her that girl will tear
out your heart put it in a blender and
hit tra head ooh extra shot you need
somebody a little more down to earth
somebody with some Integrity somebody
with red hair oh and full pouting lips
what a green jacket and a name tag dude
you're the cartoon wolf man may I be of
some assistance Stanley
ypus I'm Peggy Brandt from the Tribune
look I canceled my subscription because
they kept stealing my paper from oh
no actually I just want to ask you a few
questions about what Ripley Auto
finishing you're a customer of theirs
aren't you wow thorough me no I don't
even have a car you don't own an 89
Civic wow you just got their whole like
receipt file and everything It's All
Coming Back to Me Jesus what did you say
your name was Peggy Brandt Peggy Brandt
you printed one of my letters last year
nice guys finish last nice gu yes wow do
you realize how much mail we got about
that letter I mean there are literally
hundreds of women out there looking for
a guy just like you oh no a a nice guy
TM you know how hard it is to find a
decent man in this town most of them
think monogamy is some kind of
wood you know it's only an H away why
are you covering this story because dear
Peggy pays dick I'm starving to death
I'm looking to become a real
reporter so many loaded lines I just
want the truth God I wish I knew the
truth you know me too you really think
hundreds of women looking for a guy like
me sure can I meet all 100 of them I'm
one of them wow oh oh my dude what a the
the me cute on that jeez next time why
don't you call right leave the delivery
boys at
home oh Jesus this guy reminds me of
Chris sanon but it's not Chris sandon
whoa what do we got
oh Jeeps you will be the
tea
the cops uh tried to shut the club down
this morning oo they say you've been
using the place to run your own Small
Time scams I hear things like that I
start losing my concentration oh yeah it
goes straight to hell
oh you good
too yep out one week to get out of town
I'll usually r l go to Breaking my new
nine iron yeah this is the most Sinister
Golf Scene in cinema history
damn
oh the siren Call
summons a s song for the
alliteration please be like The Dumb and
Dumber
dream
he's so good at that at at blending the
swaave the timing but the
wacky so much
[Applause]
[Music]
punctuation oh
my yep oh yep Milo stop it stop it Tina
come
on we
can my
n your
buddy bombshell
explodes I always wonder where we got
that term for beautiful blonde
[Laughter]
people the solution to my confidence and
assertiveness issue is simply that I
need to become this wacky man with a
green
[Music]
face
oh did it pull you that
time hold on Sugar Daddy's got a sweet
too tonight oh yes careful you don't
catch a cavity oh damn that was good
that's good great minds hey whoa Sweeney
te careful somebody stop
hey damn can't make the scene if you
don't have the green I better make a
little
St kids used to say that all the time
smoking and somebody stopped
me how's it going F looking good here my
man my man I got to get downstairs and
make sure I've seen a I saw that the
doctor is about to operate I would love
it if this guy is just Doctor Who on on
like a sidebar his outfits like he could
be and his Vibe if he was a little more
Whimsical I'm sad he works
[Music]
for sorry fellas why
not so he just rob the bank or is he
just taking the money for
safekeeping that's not that guy with the
long hair look familiar too it's not
Chris hod doll is it this is the
official movie of that gu whose name I
can't
[Music]
pull oh that not Tom Cruz guy looked a
little familiar too not Tom cruz/ notot
Dennis
Quaid
oo
uh are you on the list but I believe my
friends are perhaps you know
them Grant and
Jackson
my friends George Washington George
Washington George Washington George
Washington
Etc hey the door man is is is not Kevin
Pollock is it I don't think so it looks
kind of like him most beautiful flower
of the Coco Bango Miss Tina car let's
go Jessica
[Music]
Rabbit o
is she
[Music]
singing It's like just like a rabbit but
also like where is this in relation to
cool world isn't there like a blonde
torch singer lady in cool
[Music]
world great example of makeup working
with an actor
w and probably very handy that it's
green given the CGI embellishments they
undoubtedly have to do we got trouble he
better come upstairs that's not Cru at
all kind of looks like Brad derf but
also not
him yep and it's like when the CG could
be better like it's fine because it's
supposed to be cartoony although part of
me wonders what it would look like if
they did some actual like Roger Rabbit
handdrawn
style for a moment like this for example
but
but also I mean that looked great like
that was really funny let's rock this
joint
whoa oh
[Music]
yeah
baby this is like an Ultimate Fantasy if
you could bust up into some joint and be
like change the music and now I'm going
to stop the show with my dance moves
like
[Music]
heyy
yeah
oh and very easy to swap out with a
stunt man for him if you need to or a
stunt
dancer someone hit the joint before we
cut uh-oh suck suck on
it no that guy this man my
oh that
guy that's the guy that guy dancing with
he's dead deed me
James
whoa good framing yeah like there's a
lot of stuff that needs to be on point
for a movie like this to
[Music]
work
hey
[Music]
wow
oh
my
wow knock the socks
off what a
cun no his his PJs you think I'm joking
come on move I like that this guy has
risen you know to such a status as a
Hench but with you know those luscious
locks I want to know what my money is
and I want to know right now
okay oh
[Music]
you've got 17.5% in tea bills amortized
over the fiscal year fortunately funeral
bouquet are deductible hey yes it's a
business
expense oh
who are you trying to tell me that I can
dodge
splits hey you got to get that Russian
dance in there got to get an Elvis in
[Music]
there how many bullets all right got me
partner I did it only took me like eight
shots to get
there yes go bugs me close
red H any am the little yell her
out teeth Telly Tim I would be coming
home this Christmas yes yet every death
tell Scarlet I do give
[Music]
Dam thank
you this is great you really love me
this is like the perfect movie for Jim
Carrey back to the show hey Callaway so
you got a warrant this time or you just
stop by for a night Gap oh what I got is
probable cause couple of your boys were
spotted knocking over red City Bank easy
Juni give me a
wood I am erected why aren't you arre we
got a stiff upstairs it's one the guys
from the heights call that high price
lawyer of yours Terrell you and I are
going downtown for a little chat he that
other cop who just came in looks like he
could be like a Jim Carrey
double oh no of course both explains
part of the physics of his costume
change kiss but it also
provides yes good dramatic piece of
obstacle uh
embellishment oh my God you got to get
that thing a body pillow
dude who yep yep yep yep does the mask
not work during the daytime open up I'm
getting my oh my God and the
Frisbee
wow listen this isn't the uh best time
right now I just oh where were you last
night IUS here what do you know about
this mask character mask he robs the
bank you work in and then I find this in
the cocoa Bongo there can't be two
idiots with pajamas like these that
looks like was something someone wear to
the cocoa Bongo may I see those pajamas
Mr ripus those uh those pajamas were
stolen somebody stole your
[Music]
pajamas I mean dude what is uh what is
this City coming to just hanging off the
door knob handle whatever P drawer is no
longer safe oh he does have a little
birdie look at that guy nobody's at fast
at my bank I'll
[Music]
say they're just treating it like he's
abnormally fast the bank employee files
and run on the prints on a guy named
ipus Stanley ipus you figure was an
inside job huh that's right and all I
need is a couple of Prince to lock this
whack job up till doomsday and some more
of America's favorite fr R thank you to
McDonald's for sponsoring this scene I
want you to get the word out I want him
here tomorrow alive how about tonight
you're losing it Dorian I'm not losing
anything except maybe some extra baggage
around here yeah you weren't putting up
much of a fight with that freak Show
last night when he tried to kiss you did
it look like I had much of a choice yeah
he seduced me with cartoon physics I'll
tell you one thing it's going to be
payback for anybody who crosses me this
movie also has the right amount of
seriousness when it needs to like the
the crime scenes have to be committed
enough have a crisis on our hands here
and you stroll in over an hour late if I
have to put up with your sloly behavior
back off monkey boy Whoa monkey bone
before I tell your daddy you're running
this place like it's your own personal
piggy bank or maybe we should call the
IRS and see if we can arrange a little
vacation for you at Club ooh here's the
thing monkey boy that'll be all ifus
damn dog you just fight clubbed your
manager that was genius buddy what side
of Whose Bed did you wake up on man The
Mask side of my own two tickets to the
charity ball at the Coco Bango Club this
Saturday night want to be my date oh
you're you shouldn't have I just wanted
to thank you but I'm not sure if I'm
going to have much to open account with
anymore what about the club I thought
you were doing great oh no crime sales
are down you didn't stop by just to see
me did you it's okay tell me God that
that suit she's got the guy they say Rob
this ni I think he was at the club last
night really I think that's a solid
guess a solid
conjecture you ought to see him
dance she's not about the looks why are
you interested just curious I
guess you'd like to see him again
wouldn't you this is a very Peter Parker
kind of moment I um wouldn't
mind I know him you know I'm his
photographer we're old college buddies
him and me it's funny you should mention
the way dances because oh no I taught
him a couple of dance moves myself ohuh
do you think you can have him meet me
tonight I might be able to work
something out oh Landfield Park okay
Sunset perfect super
hey Jesus looks like fourth or fifth
century Scandinavian possibly a
representation of one of the Norse
Knight Gods maybe Loki ly the god of
Marvel who's who's ly god of
we need to get you a Disney Plus account
Odin banished him from Valhalla
forever then he could have banished him
into that mask why not this is a piece
of wood but it's green my book is about
masks as a metaphor Mr epas not to be
taken literally you're suffering from a
mild delusion uh-oh I'm going to prove
it to
you
uh yeah he crosses his
eyes
sing Michigan jrog sing
[Music]
dance you got to get that Jim Carrey hip
thrust you said Loki was a night God
maybe it only works at night it there we
go if you would like me to arrange for a
safe environment for you tonight I can
do that no no I have a tate I've got a C
Tina do I go as myself or the mask if I
tell you you promise to leave my office
right now
[Laughter]
go as yourself and as the mask yes are
both one and the same beautiful person
hey oh he empowered him just as much as
he was like
[Music]
sched oh hey hey he's got a document
Stanley what are you doing here I I just
wanted to come by and and make sure that
you two got together all right oh you
know I I hardly ever stopped by here
it's kind of hard to believe it was just
a garbage heap wow uh it's really
beautiful right around Sunset look at
that
Borealis city of
methane Sky pollution just for you my
friend will be along here any minute I I
I better go oh are you sure
Stanley
oh
hello yeah is it written in the stars
that we are destined to frat eyes oh
kiss me my dear and I will
[Music]
reveal yeah
dude I love it no dude you're peepy law
now you can't just be the ID you can't
just be the Mask wait I need backup and
I need it
[Music]
now I wish I could blow a smoke ring or
heart black Napoleon I
will conquer I don't know dude askar Le
got about that
police mailed mailed you knew it was
coming is that the most popular swear
word in a non-english language you're
under arrest it wasn't me it was the one
armed man yes Richard Kimbell fugitive
let's do this what are they going to do
to me S what are they going to
do
Ser ow no you got to do one of those
where's a camcorder when you need
one that line is aged
up oh my goodness never seen those
before in life I have a permit for that
concealed carry what what maret ug son
of a [__] jeez I figured you had a
sense of humor after all you married
her did she get like got to hurt yep did
she get like a professional bed
[Music]
shot this is like a monster movie where
it's like you know the the blend of
practical effects of CGI like all
enhance the thing like this is like the
comedy version of that where it's like
you have the right
performer the right makeup and then CGI
to embellish the already huge
performance open
fire oh what do you
got it oh yeah let's go hey nice cut
back costume change CH
[Music]
Maracas oh my god dude Chim Cary must do
so much
yoga
used to fair amount right there's got to
be some notable chick chicky boom set
pieces in
[Music]
movies
oh
[Music]
yes even though this is one big
distraction it's stop
B you know it's just causing unity and
joy oh who's that flying by like trape
artists there he is let's get him snap
out of it yeah were you firing at one of
the people in the
sky no oh
oh
oh look like Nick Cage for a second
there stany get in there he is damn she
going to risk her life for you
shoot stop her my mom shoot
shoot wow everybody shoot that car I saw
it what's happening to you Stanley dang
I'm losing control when I put that mask
on I can do anything be anything yeah uh
you got to combine it with your core
self or the other parts of yourself I
don't know what's happening to you
Stanley but I do know this that letter
that you sent my column that was from a
guy with more guts and more heart a
whatever that mask is you don't need it
yeah you are already all you'll ever
need to be a do you really mean
that actually no
yeah what took you guys so long I've
been here for like 20 minutes what she's
in with them give her the money I guess
that tracks both these women who are
very drawn to him kind of inexplicably
sorry Stanley but you really are a great
guy I just can't lose my condo you know
how hard it is to find an apartment in
this
city is her name piggy Brandt is there
Betty Brandt in something you said you
wouldn't hurt him hi
I
lied how's this mask work I don't know
you just put it on is it there a movie
where that actually happens and there's
like a big red smear on the paper it's
like an actual gruesome
[Music]
scene oh
no whoa but you're not the chosen one
man you don't you better be careful huh
you don't love Looney Tunes the way this
guy loves Looney Tunes you can't handle
the
slapstick
oh gigachad mask what do we do with ipus
the police are looking for the mask so
we'll give them the
mask damn though you're like the Monster
version money better be here iiss or you
can IP kiss your ass
goodbye he spent a long time coming up
with that
one
Orlando dudes used to rock the only
ponytail more back in the day I feel
like oh come on Milo you got
this Milo is intact live your best life
[Music]
boy
oh come on Milo I still can't believe it
Harden cops dancing in the street and
broadcast all over the 11:00 News the
SWAT team got an offer to open in
Vegas oh I want to see that show a come
on Lieutenant it's not all your fault
something will turn up sure Stanley ipus
is going to fall right into my
lap oh yeah yep yep yep explain
everything explain this that's a
different mask that's that's just a
prosthetic that they probably used from
one of the earlier later
scenes it's okay James James Kare
Milo oh buddy forget about me buddy find
yourself a new place to live looks like
I'm going to be in here for a long long
time no hey you with the face
you Jim Carrey is maybe the one guy that
that you would actually be able to
identify with that descriptor hello
Stanley what are you doing here is it
true yeah your boyfriend might be a
little upset he's going to the charity
ball tonight he's going to do something
terrible oh how does it work it's like
it it it brings your innermost desires
to life if deep down inside you're a
little repressed and a hopeless romantic
yeah you become some sort of a love
crazy wild man is Me Myself and Irene
kind of like that too and we're all in
big trouble and if I were you I'd get
out of town the ID versus the higher
self kind of split thanks a a sunset
with me for being the only guy who
treated me like a person and not some
sort of party favor damn you know that
night at the club I knew I'd found
someone special The Mask oh what the guy
inside the mask was you all along was
you Spider Man I've got to disappear for
a while now stanle I don't know where
I'm going to go I'll let you know as
soon as I can oh buddy you got to go
take down Venom man you got to go beat
down Eddie
Brock I like that the The Mask sorry
Edge City made me think of edge Lord and
then I was like the mask's crazy grin
almost looks like cringe
face oh no
no damn not
bad something about that moment reminded
me of like LA Confidential for some
reason oh my no this is a great w cell
window G there's a woman being a chased
through the alleyway there come on she
needs help yeah yeah sure keep it down
ipus there's another that guy
Milo remember how I taught you not to
jump up on people forget all
that all your jumping desires will be
met
today wow damn you can do it come on
what are they do is is that the dog
jumping or is someone like throwing him
up
there oh
w
[Music]
yeah when it needs to it feels like some
kind of actual crime movie I was
beginning to get all worried about you
nice little talk with the cops I just
went to see what ipus told them oh
that's right you and Stanley right maybe
it was you who helped them out with the
back job huh that's ridiculous always
he's got the left side earring what was
the politics of the time everyone's got
a left side earring you plan a little
trip without me baby no o if we're going
to go to a party tonight we're going to
have one hell of a time aren't we get in
this D I like too the the doveet tailing
of what is it Peggy being sweet coming
from like a a reputable like oh she's a
reporter and then turning out to be the
double cross and then you have Cameron
Diaz on the other side you know part of
the grift but who really just wants to
go straight and steady and leaving the
operat like that yeah I think that's
nice see that man over there he's got
keys go get those keys it's like a
reverse Pirates of the Caribbean sort of
that's it yeah come on buddy come on
buddy oh did
cheese budy come on dude come on
[Music]
dude wow this dog is well trained well
trained animal actor what's he watching
on TV good boy give me the
keys I wonder I wonder they probably
wanted the dog to keep the key but at
the same time I'm like at what point is
he just actually saying hey come on we
got to move the scene
on
oh careful
Stanley
oh oh he's going to close the
button oh Dam
Stan
Milo no I am warning you I'm seriously
stressed out here yep you're in the
middle of a police station there is no
way you're walking out of here like this
no you're
right you're absolutely right what the
hell are you doing uh you're going to
take me out as your prisoner put it on
put it on wowe that was Swift who you
taking
ipus he gay and UNG oh I get it Pig
Latin right e say
oh my goodness yes pig ltin is the
official official thing to use if you
really want someone to work hard and
then give up on whatever you just said
I've got a change for the
party
yes knock knock with the Devin mevin as
I've ever
been Casino
KN oh
yeah
[Music]
like Goro and the Hulk you driving like
a maniac I'm sorry we're already late
for the
ball I'm just the next employee who's
come for his back pay or should I say
pay back yes there little spawn in there
kill
him oh he flinched a little bit when the
guns went
off woo
oh he's getting hit I see I see come on
hit
me
oh
no that's that's actually kind of
unsettling ladies and
gentlemen I will be your host for the
remainder of the evening so it amplifies
yeah the ID lurking within you that you
need to Wrangle and temper there is
everybody someone's not Kosher here
exactly what yeah com enough the lock in
use the
radio
Milo this could be dangerous you stay
here and be a good boy yes the best boy
Daddy's going to have to go kick some
ass how is daddy going to have a a
normal life after
this oh there's a jump cut there they
adjusted the timing on that shot blow
it oh no
no this is your big production number
and you know it's important to go out
with a big
bang I like that the the bad guys even
put you know cautionary signs on the
box look take this gun start sneaking
people out the back right God he looks
like a James Bond character and he looks
almost like a dirty hay dirty
Cary this part is over oh in 10
minutes just enough time when a man
shows what he's really made of oh look
out crap made of
crap
[Music]
oh where are you
going
hey boss look who decided to crash the
party this guy's familiar too bring him
up
here wait
no there's no time for last request but
all I wanted was a kiss uhoh Dorian I
can't shut this thing off there's always
time for a kiss EG from the real Doran
the one I used to love oh smart this
whole place is going to blow in a couple
couple minutes yeah just
wait look at those lips they gave him
too those details I
decided I have
decided hey one last through a lot of
buildup for that
cut oh yeah oh
yeah excellente
[Music]
no
oh
oh oh we're doing that the Frisbee the
frisbee
excellent it's all over
now oh
[Music]
ouch oh no
oh they're doing it they're doing
it oh my God no oh how many things is
this dog going to
hump
[Music]
yep no
nope damn dude it's going Ralphie Parker
on him
[Music]
Nice Shot nicely done with that Dolly
embellishment
waa got to get him on the butt got to do
all the dog
jokes oh my God this has got to be a new
breed yes the new breed the new
batch oh oh buddy okay I'm happy Milo
got to wear the mask but I'm also happy
that was
shortlived excellent shooting gang
excellent work
today oh did you miss
[Music]
me
classic stick Tracy over here now you
you have to ask yourself one question do
I feel
lucky well
oh do I do
you was it Bruce Almighty that made his
face like look like Clint would to do
that same
line stany excellent but that is the
difference between what Stanley would do
and what the other guy would
do a
[Music]
wow Yep this guy is
encourageable God his jaw action hey
smart smart good thing you didn't get
any Acme products along the way oh
nice you were good kid real good
long as I'm around you'll always be
second best see those teeth
[Music]
man oh see you're learning to balance
you're learning to apply what the mask
can teach you but curb its basist
instincts and
desires police hands
up officers arrest those men
oh I've always wanted to say that you
know I'll give it to you man you are not
a good wingman at all but I'll give it
to you man is the mask no Dorian Tyrell
was the mask I saw with my own ass yes
smart wow you're a real hero ah any
American with balls of steel wouldn't do
for his community yep you sure you know
what you're doing buddy I'm sure go exit
The Truman Show you sure you're not
going to miss this guy when he's gone
all that's left is me
a he's looking at you
kid a the
kiss we did it we got that
[Applause]
[Music]
kiss where are you going dude you're
just going to
leave oh my God Jesus Christ no Father
in Heaven please not this
guy this guy does not get the mask oh
Milo what the hell see I
can yeah see see it's in
you just got to make sure to keep it
proportional and want a freeze frame to
end on that was so lovely oh my
goodness oh oh my
friends gonna gonna take a minute to
drink in the cast right here but but we
did it thank you to Rocket money for
sponsoring this video a brand that I am
happy to be partnered with thrilled to
it's fortunately one that I have been
using for quite a while now prior to
ever agreeing to a partnership with them
I was like that makes for the best kind
of synergy promotion because I can
actually talk about them from my heart
here reason being like many of you guys
uh like for years I constantly
downloading all kinds of financial apps
that I keep forgetting to use or I don't
really find quite as beneficial rocket
money has been the one the only one I'm
not just saying it is the only one that
I have been able to consist recently use
ReliOn that has been an absolute game
Cher for me on a very personal note
running real rejects is an absolute
privilege however you know like I stress
out about taxes and it's the beginning
of the year and I'm like I'm trying to
be smarter and get it all done now I
already started like a couple months ago
getting things in order managing real
rejects finances while managing my own
personal finances has been an ongoing
struggle and I'm very big on like
efficiency and being organized but
clearly wasn't as good enough as I uh
thought I had been so before rocket
money came into my life I was drowning
in subscriptions and struggling to keep
track of my expenses and as I really
wanted to like get everything in order
rocket money came at the right time for
me I was overwhelmed with subscriptions
I didn't even know I had or had still
been subscribed to I mean do you ever
wonder how many subscriptions you
actually pay for have you ever taken the
time to really do it it could be a
little daunting rocket money helped me
see what I was missing and best part
they even cancelled those subscriptions
for me with just a simple tap so with
rocket money you can have all your
subscriptions in one place making it
easy to cancel anything unnecessary
without the hassle of dealing with
customer service my is so annoying plus
they'll work on getting you refunds and
negotiate lower bills saving you up to
20% you just snap a pick of your bill
and let rocket money take care of the
rest let me just summarize for you
really quick what they are they're
personal finance app that fines and
cancels unwanted subscriptions monitors
your spending and helps lower your bills
with over 5 million users and over $500
million and cancel subscriptions they've
already saved members an average of $720
a year they helped save me a little bit
more than that don't waste your hard
earn money on unused subscriptions
cancel them today at Rocket money.com
rejects that's rocket money.com rejects
if you've heard other people talk about
them well use ours Rocky money.com
rejects cuz if you use that promo code
rejects you unlock special benefits and
yes using them is also a great way to
support the channel same time it's just
a great way to support your bank account
cuz I cannot stress enough just how much
this app has changed the game for me
take control of your finances with
rocket money and enjoy Financial Peace
of Mind oh guys hey first and foremost
before we hop into this review uh why
don't you go ahead leave five stars if I
could I would have had uh you know my
hand stretch out and you know do some
kind of crazy number five thing but yeah
if you're listening on Apple and Spotify
uh leave us your thoughts and opinions
but mostly leave us that rating helps us
out a lot and uh you know what I got to
say first and foremost Jim Carrey
Stanley ipus the mask in particular the
drips throughout this movie The Costume
design was lovely and terrific and I
mean across the board from again just
like the The Outfits they had Cameron
Diaz in the outfits that they had the
freaking pajamas they had Jim Cary in
all the different elegant partygoers the
criminals the biker gangs so many great
flourishes in terms of uh wardrobe and
Aesthetics and speaking of wardrobe and
it's just regation shop.com if you want
to support the channel and uh Rock aresh
and uh
reject Nation drip uh come on over there
it's a great way to support the channel
it's one of our favorites we got new
designs going up quite frequently I made
a bunch of Doctor Who jokes during this
and Doctor Who we got a do Doctor Who
Inspire t-shirt it's one of the best
sellers thus far we got space babies of
the Galaxy we got Child Protection
Services the Classic ticket we got a
whole bunch of other things are probably
flashing up on screen but yeah if you
want to jump on over there and I will
finish Shilling and uh move on to
talking about this movie it's so cool to
finally yeah to finally fill in again
one of the fun things about this whole
experience is that you know yes we get
to talk about the current things and
break those down and kind of you know
give our thoughts and ideas about him
but it's always a blast and it feels
like continuing you know Film School in
some kind of cultural way when we get to
watch one of these Classics and and yeah
this was hilarious like this this really
lived up to just the Mystique that it is
crude over time at least for you know my
perception of it uh and and you know
going back to especially a comedy you're
always like how is this going to hold up
by today's standards and just by where I
am as a viewer Now versus like if I had
seen this when I was like you know
between 10 and 15 or something like that
you know
I might have you know really had a blast
but actually this is an example of a
movie where you know watching it now
gave me so much lovely appreciation for
the context just as much as just the the
direct experience of watching the movie
because yeah I mean this was really fun
and funny and it was really fun to see
Jim Carrey in you know his Heyday uh you
know and at the height of his comedic
you know presence in Hollywood before I
think this is like what slightly before
or maybe even a good stretch before he
was breaking out into more dramatic
roles and things like that um but it
really just gives you that huge
appreciation like I I I feel like Jim
Carrey wasn't prominent in my house
growing up because of just like the
overwhelming stick is stick is nature of
his whole you know onscreen Persona uh
and then we might not have had an Adam
Sandler for the broadness but also the
the crudeness the crassness and whatnot
um and so yeah this was fun because you
know I've been able to go back and
appreciate you know some of the stuff
that I missed from the Jim Carrey
catalog up until now uh and like Dumb
and Dumber was another one of those
where I'm like this is a perfect movie
for this guy and it's funny that this
should be like a comic book thing
because we've talked about you we did
like a Batman movie ranking a couple
years ago and I watched Batman Forever
for that and uh and Batman Forever is an
example of one of those that you know
Jim Carrey is in that that represents
sort of what I uh was maybe repelled by
or didn't love back in the day which is
that you know I know a lot of people
love his ridd I know this is kind of a
hot take but yeah I found it mostly just
kind of loud and obnoxious and it didn't
really click in for me whereas this is
an example of a character uh like with a
comedian like this I I guess for my
taste I like to see something that
requires them to fully play a character
along with bringing their natural uh you
know n their stick whatever it is
there's a reason and I know again a lot
of people don't love this movie
problematic or whatever like an Adam
Sandler movie that I love that I
gravitate towards Like You Don't Mess
with the Zohan because he's a full-on
character there and here I feel like
this is a great balance of Jim Carrey
being you know the Everyman kind ofish
guy plus wackiness that you require from
you know the the more traditional
comedic and romantic things that this
movie is going for but yeah you need
somebody who can embody this Looney Tune
character and I don't know much about
the mask as a comic or as a strip or
anything like that but from what this is
telling me you know it's basically a
superhero that you know has those kinds
of powers and Aesthetics it's all
slapstick it's all comedic it's all very
animated and very steeped in the
tradition of animation and for me as a
viewer that converges on a whole bunch
of things that I love and I thought yeah
Jim Carrey was absolutely perfectly
suited for because again he's got the
crazy physicality and the rubber face
and all that stuff but I think that one
thing that I wouldn't have picked up if
I had seen this and and really been able
to perceive it back in the day is how
that stuff is great and funny and and
you know well timed and all that stuff
like the comedy is really on but you
have to be able to temper that with uh
you know the right emotionality when a
scene needs to be a little more straight
or a little more heartfelt or whatever
it might be and like this is an example
of a movie where I think he's really
good at that and there are other movies
you know in his film that I have seen
that you know adjust the levels on that
and maybe play a little more Earnest
than something like this does um but I
was just so dazzled by and swept up by
this because yeah the whole movie F uh
felt like it embodied that sensibility
you know it had enough uh you know
straight
shooting a little shooting sound of the
other credits there to punctuate that
perfect uh you know it knew when to take
like the crime scenes seriously uh at
least enough and I'm going to pull up
the IMDb because again this is this is
like a movie full of that guys um but
yeah like this movie knew when to play
seriously enough and I thought all the
actors they got even in smaller roles
like some of the henches there are these
character actors or on the police force
like they all fill out the cast really
well and again they can all contend with
and compete with Jim Carrey and
compliment Jim Carrey and provide the
proper foils Peter ryer okay he was the
cop Peter Green was Dorian I feel like
these are you know uh uh faces I would
have been yeah Richard Jenny used to
seeing maybe more uh you know just back
in the day or in these yeah older uh in
an older era of movies um okay this
guy's Z in Pulp Fiction and things like
that like yeah it's it's like I I like
that he got to Dawn the mask and and get
a little wacky as well um but that yeah
yeah you have this movie that knows
appropriately when to play Broad and
early on when to kind of throw you into
the quirkiness kind of making you wonder
like is this a fantasy is this a dream
no I guess okay so it establishes the
height of its World already and then
adds The Mask into that you need the
right amount of tempering to make a
movie like this work and I think that
also ties into the message of the movie
which is you know it's another one of
those classic stories where it's about
yeah you get this McGuffin that brings
out a certain aspect of your character
uh that you initially think just doesn't
exist within you at all it allows you to
become a whole new kind of person that
has these qualities that maybe you have
wished you could possess and then slowly
learning no these do exist inside you
you just have repressed them and some of
them yeah are are urges you need to curb
and or quash and you know maybe yeah
build out of your approach to living um
but some of the these things you do do
need a little bit more of you know you
could stand to be a little bit more
forward or expressive or whatever it
might be and I'm wondering now if uh if
Me Myself and Irene doesn't have a
similar kind of quality but maybe you're
like splitting those aspects up into two
different people or something either way
you know like there's enough going on
that this felt like super appropriate to
what it is or at least again the the
prospect of a comic strip with this
conceit adapted into a motion picture
and yeah I really like the effects um
you know it is CG you know I think a
Roger Rabbit would be certainly a
comparison Point here and that dazzles
with its blend of 2D with yeah 2D
classic animation drawn animation with
liveaction stuff um but yeah this had
you know more of a CGI approach to that
which you know at the time I imagine
this was probably pushing the boundaries
of what CG can do which is cool to see
and it's one of those things where yeah
even if it doesn't look photo real
that's okay and that probably helps you
know like the cartoonishness probably
helps just as a nerd I would have loved
to have seen a couple gags that were in
the handdrawn tradition but uh again you
know the blending it's like I said
during the the reaction it's like a lot
of especially apparent in Monster movies
and things like that is is you know the
combination of physical and visual and
makeup effects you know to sell monsters
or or action and this movie kind of
helped me to to further clarify the idea
that slapstick is like the action
iteration of Comedy you know it's it's
it's that thing that involves stun and
specific timing and all those things and
so yeah this is kind of like a monster
movie in a way but with comedy instead
so you have this prosthetic makeup that
you know helps to enhance the natural uh
zaniness of Jim Carrey's expressions and
whatnot and then you have the you know
just way in which he is so beautifully
able to you know beyond that yeah you
know create these
punctuated uh you know emotions and
expressions and things and then you know
you can take that you know further into
fantasy with the use of CG and other
things and yeah this was a movie that
required a combination of effects and
stuff and and funny you know yeah the
mask should be green so I can only
imagine that that probably just helped
the effects as much as it did just you
know stay true to what I imagin the
original design would have been um and
yeah like there's a lot of other comic
book movie aspects to this as well that
aren't doing it the way it not as much
doing it like you would see them today
where it's like hey we're paying homage
it's like no like their aspects of this
like especially when um the villain gets
the mask uh and he's you know basically
turning into like the Venom version It's
like a kind of like a dark Spider-Man
Peter Parker thing and you know Tina
comes to see him and she's got this
whole thing where she is drawn to
Stanley but she's also drawn to the mask
But ultimately it's really the qualities
of Stanley that she's actually you know
responding to um and you know certainly
other flourishes and certain tonal
things felt like maybe it could have
been hearkening to spawn which I haven't
seen as a movie but I'm familiar with at
least some of the iconography of and it
also has that you know bit with Loki
where they you know acknowledge the the
myth you know obviously Marvel and
create that although that's a fun thing
reminiscent of other mythology and
Comics it does enough just enough with
that benstein character to address that
idea of the theme of The Masks we put on
the people we aspire to be and I love
that that moment plays out with him
basically just actually encouraging him
despite the obvious awkwardness of the
situation and the fact that he thinks
he's bit deranged he's still like go as
both people be yourself but also brings
out some of those more assertive
qualities that you think you could
benefit from and realize that they're
both just you and even though yes I mean
there is a McGuffin there is some sci-fi
thing happening here with an actual
magic mask you know it's like you didn't
have to do that and I feel like a lot of
movies nowadays wouldn't weave a theme
that way the way that this movie did you
know and yeah you know like classic film
Noir things or things like Dick Tracy
uh which is another thing I should see
at some point but yeah there were
certainly like film Noir crime classic
tropes here you've got the you know the
uh what do they call it the Coco uh Coco
Bongo the you know Copa Cabana style
like you know big band club and you know
your fem fatals and you've got your you
know journalist who turns out to be like
a double cross and you know the food
chain of crime and the cops and
everything and yeah this just managed to
blend so many things together it's a fun
mad cap way and to have you know like
again a story that matches your
requisite comedy for this time period
especially where it's just like yeah a
you know nice guy who's a little bit
timid and maybe a bit down on his luck
trying to you know uh improve his life
and and you know get the good gig and
get the girl and all that other you know
basic stuff and uh and yeah it's got
that uh and it's got you know a bit of a
romance but then yeah it's got this
whole superhero Thing and multiple
identities thing without having to get
too overwrought with any of those
qualities and in a way that yeah lets
the imagination and the fun and the
wildness shine and you get some of the
you know awkward comedy of you know like
discovery of of how this thing works and
how it you know uh interacts with
regular people and how to you know
stifle the the aftermath it's like when
he's trying to clean up the apartment
when the cops at his door uh you know
and sort of learning to harness this
force that has you know come into your
life and even just the Simplicity of the
opening of you know You' got this diver
and there's almost like a peripheral
magic where this diver goes down opens
the chest The Mask floats out you get
the sense that it's something that was
put there you know long ago for you know
a reason washed away by time and then
you know the pipe immediately Falls and
knocks the dude out and then you know
even the way he finds it and then even
those moments that like it I like when
movies and I feel like this used to
happen more in the past when they'll
remind you of things and Nod to stuff
but again it's more it's it's not really
taking any kind of break not that movies
directly say that but I think there is
more of like you'll see movies now with
a greater sensibility of like oh let's
leave an Applause break here you know
like they're they're not doing that so
it's kind of up to you to just catch
these things and and appreciate them or
not um but yeah like I thought it was
rich with those things and I really like
the chemistry of Cameron Diaz and I
bought uh Amy yasbeck uh you know the
Peggy Brandt like you know even though
again this isn't the kind of movie where
we can spend the utmost amount of time
with those characters the classic tropes
help you to identify with who they are
and then you know you like uh Peggy
enough and she's Charming enough that
when that double cross happens it is a
major surprise and you are bummed
because at least for me early on I was
like man they both seem like kind of
kind of great like I could see how he
would be great with either of them in in
one way or another um and so yeah this
is an example of a movie that you know
it feels more classic because yeah it's
doing all the craziness that you would
expect and it certainly is a vehicle for
presence like Jim Carrey um but it seems
like a lot of care went into how to
shoot this and how to you know bring
energy to everything that was going on
cuz sometimes comedies can be shot flat
even effects comedies can be shot kind
of flat aside from their you know set
pieces whereas this yeah I just felt
like one of those older movies where
like every little thing had a joke on it
everything had color even the incidental
things had some type of Personality
there are a lot of great character
actors across the board and uh and yeah
man like this is great I had such a I so
I I as much as you know again people
going to be like how' you never like you
know being aware of it for so long this
was about as lovely as I could have
hoped for for finally paying off this
experience and uh and yeah like I cannot
wait to watch this again like this is
it's yeah the full peak of zany you know
sort of overwhelming Jim car and you can
see certainly variations of the kind of
movie that would become a Jim Carrey
movie in light of something like this
um but yeah man this was just such a
blast and I thought it was really well
you know attuned to what it was trying
to be it had just the right amount of
tempered dimensionality uh to you know
sell all the things it was trying to
sell I don't really know much of of I
feel like this director's named Chuck
Russell is kind of familiar um but yeah
yeah just the idea of a Looney Tune hero
or not even hero it's not even superh
hero that's the thing it's like you
could be but it's yeah it's all about
how you use it ah this guy directed the
Scorpio and King and Nightmare on Elm
Street 3 okay Dream Warriors one of the
best ones not bad at all okay um so yeah
man I was really enthralled by this this
was super fun and uh and yeah I mean I
don't really know what else you could
say about it uh just firing on all
cylinders lots of craftsmanship and good
you know visual work on display and uh
yeah a real marriage of every facet of
film making and movie Magic coming
together so hey guys leave me your
thoughts and uh yeah what else should I
check out what are the Jim Carrey movies
I've seen a handful of his Classics but
there's certainly ones I haven't seen
and certainly ones where you know I
would have probably been so young that
if I had been in the room for them I
don't remember them now so yeah I'm
excited like again Dumb and Dumber and
now this have me very excited to check
out more Jim Carrey uh you know Classics
moving on cuz uh cuz yeah and especially
in the day and age of the comic book
movie this holds up like really well for
the most part and it's not even there
aren't a ton of things it's like even
within its own internal logic and it's
not a movie that requires you to be too
anal specific about the internal logic
you're like the rules are fun and
fanciful and you can ask questions about
them but there's enough of everything
and enough thought of everything to I
don't know just yeah sell them very
nicely and in a time where you know
again we are so saturated with this kind
of thing albeit not in this tone at all
uh and and as comic book movies try to
figure out how to reincorporate humor
without making themselves a joke I feel
like there's such a stigma from the time
in which people just didn't take
anything comic book seriously before you
proved through a Batman or something
that they could be serious uh yeah I I
feel like now we're in this weird place
with comic book humor where you know you
could stand to learn a thing or two from
a movie like this not that everything
has to be slapstick but anyway yeah I I
really appreciated this and I hope you
did too uh so hey leave me your thoughts
and I'll catch you on the next one much
love and hey before we go let's do a
patron of the day shout
out Eric Horseman what's up buddy listen
uh I just wanted to say if there's
anybody it's a classic John shout out
cuz if there's anybody at patreon I
would be thrilled to see Dawn the mask
and who they turn into under those you
know circumstances and pretenses it's
you buddy I mean the amount I feel like
you would be like the PE sort of like uh
Tasmanian Devil pepy law kind of
presence very very I don't know if you
would be a bugs or a Daffy see that's
the thing there's so many possibilities
and uh yeah and you're a colorful guy
you've got the rejects to two which
would probably like come to life the
real would Spin and it would like pop
out in 3D and there would be flames you
could use it to light a cigar
cigar at and then it would explode uh
you know all the possibilities and then
you could you know tornado your way out
here sweep us up take us back to Atlanta
and you can show us around and uh I just
think that that would be a lovely and
wonderful experience so hey work on that
get yourself a voodoo mask and uh I'll
catch you on the next one but seriously
here at the start of the year you know
seeing your name in in our you know
Master list here just the amount of love
you have shown us the amount of time
you've dedicated to just you know being
on this ship with us and being
supportive and being lovely really
really appreciate you and uh yeah much
love for now and we'll catch you next
time Eric and everyone
else all right that's the video
[Music]
cheers